bonjour à tous alors comme présenté jeu
sial et il faut savoir que moi à
voulait faire des gâteaux oui dans le
gâteau statistiques effectivement
voulez-vous dire qu'est-ce que je fais
là il va fois c'est une bonne question
bref après sept années d'études trois
mémoires de domaine de spécialité
je ne peux pas répondre à cette question
j'ai des amis aussi qu'ils ont un
résident de m'aider j'étais à leur
mariage donc conviés à leur table et au
moment des remerciements
le marié se lève qui renverse le monde
et puis là il ya cyril on sent
l'hésitation on sait pas ce qu'il fait
là mais et on les aime bien donc vous
pouvez le voir j'ai un petit peu arrêter
de planifier ma vie maintenant je
m'adapte après tout pourquoi j'aurais
justifié pas on n'est pas bien ensemble
pourquoi justifié bain ce qui paraît les
gens qui aiment bien les histoires c'est
un petit peu le principe des toc
on raconte une histoire les gens sont
contents on aime bien aussi les entendre
on aime bien se justifier et on aime
aussi beaucoup justifiée notamment lors
des échecs
lorsqu'on y arrive pas donc non en faite
pas faire des gâteaux s'est passé pas un
échec je vous rassure et donc pour les
échecs en général ce que les gens ils
aiment bien parce que je remarque
souvent c'est qu'ils appliquent elle
technique perfectionne depuis leur
tendre enfance ils disent c'est pas moi
donc imaginez bien le petit bambin au
chocolat jusque dans le dos c'est pas
moi pourquoi le powerpoint n'est pas
prêt pas en j'étais pas mal de fait en
fait c'est pas moi il y en a qui pose le
truc tellement a qui disent c'est pas
moi c'est la société
c'est l'ensemble des interactions
individuelle des individus convergentes
or la sns est même pas royals et
empirique est carrément wii black de
sociologues et donc l'une des
justifications que je préfère c'est
lorsque les gens raguet et se foire est
entendue donc on a le droit pour les
femmes
elle aime que les connards ou pour les
hommes
ils comprennent pas les petits signes
qui comprennent pas donc l'eau ce soir
la dernière en date c'était une amie on
discute et qu'elle était partie obama
compte asseoir et donc il était parti
chasser ou bien entendu et si je raconte
l'histoire ce qu'elle est rentrée
bredouille
bien entendu donc au fil de discussion
la rive mais les mecs et gnagnagna ça
comprend rien le rituel et comme j'ai
entendu cette phrase je ne sais combien
de fois je m'entends très bien qu'elle
signait alors elle était là tout
sérieuse
à 6 pi et lui ai fait un sourire un vrai
sourire sourire ravageur bon
pourquoi pas alors maintenant je demande
d'imaginer la scène un homme une femme
un sourire mais rien ne se passe et le
mec ne comprends pas mais pourquoi
d'ailleurs ici regza pas déjà l'info qui
voit sourire parce qu'il est peut-être
sa pote aussi qui lui souriait des coups
il a vu sa pote on va être de bonne foi
on va lui accorder le fait que
effectivement les hommes ça comprend pas
les signes faut qu'il soit disponible
intéressé par l intéressé par sa pote
qui à côté qu'est ce qui faut d'autres
qui soient pas timide bien sûr qu'ils
aient le courage d'aller parler ou
encore qu effectivement 26 comprend pas
le petit s'il attend ans qui part
deuxième signe pour pas se prendre un
gros at home devant tout le monde
donc voilà nous avons huit possibilités
et on a carte qu'un seul pas elle tout
le monde n'en garder qu'un seul toujours
on comprend pas bon bah comme je lui ai
dit effectivement comme j'ai l'habitude
si jamais tu appliques toujours la même
chose si jamais ça ne marche jamais
pourquoi tu t'es pas lui tout simplement
vous tu te lèves et tu vas lui parler
alors là par contre je manquais plus de
la suite c'était tellement brouillon son
explication qu'on sentait c'était
horrible donc on va retourner à la scène
et cette fois on va un petit peu les
pury vous êtes là vous êtes sassi est ce
que vous voulez se trouve devant vous
tout ce que vous avez à faire c'est
tendre la main
euh bon effectivement dans ce contexte
de la drague elle avec ses amis il est
avec ses amis et kuala il ya quand même
la petite peur du rejet mais bon est-ce
que ça change quelque chose
ol lui demander à lui de voir perdre sa
place
elle demandait à la personne en face de
surmonter ses peurs et ensuite devenir
du coup maintenant ça va être sa
responsabilité
donc vous allez me dire effectivement là
par contre un petit peu de
responsabilité partagée du coup je vais
vous raconter une deuxième histoire
cette fois c'était durant un de mes
stages intervenait dans un immeuble
social vous était député-maire sociaux
et nous avons une personne qui
pourrissait la vie de tout le monde
j'avais accès au dossier des plaintes
j'ai regardé effectivement ça durait
depuis quand même ya quelques mois tout
le monde s'en plaignait alors le
bailleur m'a demandé s'il te plaît
peux-tu regarder ce qui se passe parce
que nous là tout le monde se plaint et
malheureusement rien ne se passe
donc j'y vais j'y vais j'ai interroge
les gens en disant oui bon bah là donc
effectivement la personne en question
pourrit la vie de tout le monde
depuis un an ils n'aident en plus ils
sont stressés qu'en iront chez eux à la
et cetera et cetera donc par contre ce
qui ressortait c'était toujours le
bailleur social ne fait rien parce que
la situation ne change pas
malheureusement comme le bailleur
c'était aussi mon employeur moi je vais
demander plus demandés qui avait ouvert
bas à rien parce qu'on peut rien faire
le seule chose qu'un bailleur peut faire
et c'est d'ailleurs moi un petit peu
tant mieux parce que c'est des
médiations ils peuvent pas footer des
gens juste parce qu'ils pourrissent
celle des autres enfin la vidéo du
pardon donc je leur ai dit est ce que
par exemple j'ai fait autre chose si
vous avez connaissance d'autres trucs
on m'a dit oui il faut faire une
pétition
mais au fait cette pétition ah non non
non non non je ne fais pas ça et là je
vais vous recommander de nouveau mais
dans la seine
vous avez un problème les aides fois
j'arrive avec mon plateau d'argent j'ai
mon plateau d'argent j'ai une petite
feuille et je vous dis que tous vos
problèmes se résoudront si jamais vous
signer des feuilles
est-ce que vous signeriez titres sur dur
parce que un immeuble de 13 personnes
donc moins une
douze personnes n'ont pas signer cette
feuille il fallait juste père ce signal
vous ne pouvez dormir vous ne serez plus
pressé alors ne sont bien sûr que deux
petits exemples mais déjà on voit qu'il
ya un refus de se remettre en cause
derrière ce n'est pas à moi de le faire
c'est à l'autre et en soi vont pas
effectivement je suis un c'est à l'autre
mais en disant toujours ce n'est pas moi
c'est la faute de l'autre il nous
arrivera toujours la même chose
si vous ne vous remettez jamais en cause
vous serez comme ces personnes vous
aurez pour vous donner les résolutions
sur un plateau d'argent
rien ne se passera donc pour conclure
moi je ne sais pas ce que je fais là bas
je sais pourquoi je sais pourquoi je
sais ce que je n'ai pas fait pour être
là et malheureusement cela a pris
plusieurs années
ben que oui après une journée pour
rendre compte que je n'ai pas ouvert des
boutiques de cadeaux et donc vu que
personne ne peut lire dans vos esprits
il faudra vous exprimer et même si
quelqu'un d'autre
peut faire le premier pas pour vous
rappelez vous qu'il faisait la même
personne présent que vous en pensez vous
et ça il faudra faire avec
merci
[Applaudissements]